you know that is how you defeat an
insurgency you do not do it with street
violence because
every insurgent you kill you make
another hundred
and this is exactly what my dad did in
world war ii he hunted what was called
werewolves which were nazis when the
reich fell went into the hills
vowed to fight the allies for a hundred
years and you know how we defeated that
insurgency
we rebuilt germany right those guys came
back out of the hills
i agree and they said hey you fritz i
got a job for you
and if we want to defuse this homegrown
insurgency i agree
we have to govern well in fact if you
look at the u.s
military's counter-insurgency manual
peel away the tactical layers
it's just a handbook for good government
but here's the problem wait we need a
marshall plan for west virginia is that
yes okay we need to
do it well no but because this is what
we've been talking about ever since i've
been on the show
globalization has ripped half the heart
out of this country
and automation is going to rip half the
other heart out and if we don't get a
handle on this
if we don't start to govern by what
affects the most
americans then we will lose again in
four years
yeah no i mean it's true i mean the
democrats lost their base
yeah of especially white working-class
voters ronald reagan right i mean the
irish were
never republicans in this country until
right reagan came along and they
they've the white working class the
democrats have the policies
that you know support the safety net and
that the working class really needs
but socially we're very very different
and it's
terrible it's terrible it's
heartbreaking for the democratic party
to have lost any of the working class
but here's the conundrum i mean yes i
agree you don't want to further
alienate the republican base the
republican voter
on the other hand the republican
leadership so has the whip hand
in how power comes about in this country
and if we get back a little of it with
biden
i think now he'd need the senate to do
this
but you need to when you have a little
of this power
especially since things are so stacked
against with the electoral college
the way it is that and senate two
senators
four from the dakotas
[Laughter]
they have how many people and 40 million
and count with these structural drivers
you have to get back power which means
packing the court
which means adding puerto rico as a
state
you have to do those moves you have to
they've shown with merrick garland and
now this and everything else trump has
done
they are no conscience about power
we need to get back power we're like
the deer hunter we're they have us you
know in that shack
playing russian roulette we got to get
more bullets in the gun
but the best way to do that is to
understand
how did trump get elected because every
fanatic no matter
nazi's communist taliban there always
starts with the kernel of a legitimate
concern correct what are those
legitimate concerns
because people who voted for obama voted
for trump absolutely my aunt who i love
in yonkers new york voted for trump
yep she's not a fanatic right why
so we can fix these problems because
look
there are issues we all agree on right
we none of us want
illegal immigration we just don't want
to treat illegal immigrants like animals
in cages
right well yes but i mean democrats did
say a lot of things during the primaries
i mean they made it sound like one come
one come all right
and you get free health care well and
that's they wanted to give there were
certain elements of our party that said
we want to give prisoners the right to
vote in prison right
i know um so
it will be nice though if i can just
fantasize for a minute
if we got back to a place where we
didn't have to operate all the time by
this is what donald trump thinks and now
we have to react to that as opposed to
just what's true or not right
donald trump thinks he didn't lose the
election and then right
it's just this bizarre for people our
age it's just
bizarre that donald trump is a joke his
whole life he was a joke
but that he controls our thinking
everything everything that we have to
pretend
all the time but the best way to to
isolate that's the thing that you do in
an insurgent
you don't destroy them you isolate them
mousy tongue said that the insurgent is
the fish that swims in the sea of
peasants
drain the sea and do that by delivering
yeah
that's how franklin roosevelt brought
about this liberal world that we all
enjoy he delivered
you